las imágenes satelitales muestran
edificios construidos durante el curso
de la invasión rusa los investigadores
de derechos humanos los han identificado
como los llamados campos de filtración
un término que se remonta a las primeras
guerras chechenas de mediados de los 90
bosworth las personas que han pasado por
los campos han denunciado humillaciones
abusos verbales y torturas físicas que
van desde chequeos al desnudo hasta
descargas eléctricas y simulacros de
ejecución
un informe de la universidad de yale ha
identificado 21 lugares de operaciones
de filtración donde se interrogan los
ucranianos se les recoge su información
personal se les toman las huellas
dactilares para luego deportarlos a la
fuerza
en una reunión del consejo de seguridad
de la onu celebrada el miércoles la
subsecretaria general de derechos
humanos dijo que entre las personas
llevadas por la fuerza a rusia hay niños
ucranianos no acompañados que luego son
dados en adopción nos preocupa que las
autoridades rusas hayan adoptado un
procedimiento simplificado para conceder
la ciudadanía rusa a los niños sin
cuidados parentales y que estos niños
puedan ser adoptados por familias rusas
sigue sin estar claro cuántos ucranianos
han sido sometidos al llamado proceso de
filtración el mes pasado funcionarios
estadounidenses afirmaron que rusia
había deportado hasta 16 millones de
ucranianos y que unos 260.000 niños
ucranianos han acabado en el este de
rusia en el martín cada vez hay más
pruebas y evidencias creíbles de que
quienes son considerados una amenaza
para el control ruso por sus supuestas
inclinaciones prou craneanas son
desaparecidos o detenidos
rusia ha negado las acusaciones de que
está deportando a ucranianos por la
fuerza afirmando que en cambio está
protegiendo a los civiles de los
soldados ucranianos